Hey everyone!Recall how strategic bargaining plays out: we use normal and sequential games to see the strategies players choose. We also considered first-mover advantage and credible threats. Let's now turn our attention to non-strategic bargaining.
Let's start with a definition:
non-strategic bargaining focuses on outside options or disagreement values.
Well that doesn't help us too much.
What are outside options or disagreement value?
Imagine you're sitting in your house. What alternatives do you have?
You could be outside side where the grass in greener.
In essence this is what we mean by outside options.
Do we have an opportunity cost with our current bargain?
If so, then we can use that as leverage. Remember the grass is always greener on the other side.
Here's Deb. Deb is a really good journalist.
But Deb wonders is there more out there for her. Can she find a better job than what she has.
Here's Steve. Steve is the current editor at Deb's news company. Steve wants to give Deb a raise. After all, she is a Pulitzer prize winner.
Steve plans to offer Deb $100,000
Under the strategic view of bargaining Deb can accept or reject the offer.
We could set up a game and solve for it. Or we could look at it another way. Suppose Deb isn't satisfied with the $100,000 offer and instead decides to negotiate.
This could turn into a repeated game.
But what if we wanted to end it without having to play multiple rounds?
This is where outside options come in.
Let's say Deb has been looking for a new job for quite some time and has a very attractive offer from a competing newspaper.
Deb can use this outside option as a means to drive negotiations in her favor.
But what if Steve has several candidates lined up to replace Deb or to add to the existing cast of journalists.
Now Steve has the larger outside offer.
What do we see? Quite simply, you can improve your bargaining position by having an outside option or larger outside option.
We don't have to consider just changing jobs. We can bargain a lot in everyday life.
One area we may choose to bargain is insurance. We simply shop around for multiple quotes to build our inventory of outside options. If you have ever purchased a home, you likely did this when selecting your home insurer.
We can also do this with our utilities at least the ones were there multiple companies such as cable and phones.
Let's conclude with a few other ways to improve your bargaining position.
First, is patience. If you are in a negotiation and the other party has a strict deadline, you might find yourself in a better bargaining position since they need to deal to close.
Do you own something that no one else has or are in a position that elevates your skill level above others?
If so you can improve your bargaining position think about your skills relative to your. Think about your skills relative to your coworkers.
Do you find yourself with a higher level of skills than them?
If so, then you may be more valuable to your company and can command a higher salary.
How reputable is a particular firm or person?
Do you know someone, or are that someone, that can close a deal?
If so, you/they probably have a reputation and this gives you bargaining power.
While not easy to obtain, if you can find out the other party's bottom line price
then you know the lower bound you can offer.
But be careful here. If you're too aggressive, the other party may simply walk away.
Lastly, let's consider signaling.
What can you tell other about yourself without explicitly stating it?
Think about getting an MBA. What exactly are you letting an employer know?
Quite simply that you are someone with an advanced degree and a higher quality applicant.
This signal can give you an edge in the job market.
Alright, that's it. Hope you've enjoyed it and we'll catch you in the next one.